hey this is Tim Sykes millionaire mentor
and trader I am here with my brand new
Ferrari there's something wrong with my
Ferrari do Ferrari suck no do they have
problems yes but that I'd much rather
have Ferrari problems than to have the
problem of working every single day
nine-to-five with a Ferrari but I hate
trying to pay down stir Ari bones trying
to pay down a Ferrari and sadly that is
the reality for most people mark is
about to open mark stomata open was
tapas sneaking was going on snake gang
what is Pappas snake gang he struggled I
struggled with life I struggled with 4x
I struggled so hard for you know years
and you know I'm only 19 so I mean I was
struggling before I was even legally
allowed to trouble 32:15 the afternoon
right now haven't even eaten nothing all
day man traitor lifestyle was really
difficult but you turn 2000 and a
million will turn twenty thousand in a
little over three million now turn
twelve thousand now into five million
dollars will stop you already sound like
all no 1.8 million guys was just last
week
how'd you do that well throughout middle
school and learning about stocks so I
started at a very little age I always
wanted to live in a whoo Josh mansion
being broken seeing my parents really
pissed me off so I said I'm gonna go out
there and really make a lot of money
millions of dollars worth of gold and
you know three years later look at me
now this could be if you work hard are
you trying to catch the [ __ ] car
embarrassing elevator pitch
I don't know sounds good geez yeah what
I want I want your opinion like what do
you think about courses common sense
would say like if you're millionaire and
you're doing greater than why bother
second course exactly okay
what's your response okay what trumps
all those like critics
Oh hold on though yeah so again why why
Stella course I'm a 26 year old Forex
trader and I've helped thousands of
people become successful in forex
trading besides just making money for
myself I love helping others make money
so I have thousands of students now in
over 60 countries while helping
thousands of my students do the exact
same thing what else do I need
do I need to screams I don't I don't
need to look like a professional because
I don't I'm not a professional I'm a day
trader
[Music]
what is Papa's snake gang